Hello and welcome,
everyone. This is active inference
Livestream. Guest stream number 54.1.
It's August 25, 2023.
Today we're going to be hearing about
electromagnetic field topology as a
solution to the boundary problem of
consciousness. This is going to be a
copresentation, followed by a discussion
with our guests here. So I will leave it
to everyone to introduce themselves and
present and discuss however they prefer.
And thank you again for joining.
Please. Thank you so
much for having us, Daniel. Yeah. I'm
Andres Co, founder of Qualia Research
Institute. And, yeah, I'm here with
Liber Chris, co author of this paper,
and Lieber, a volunteer and Wiki
extraordinaire for QRI. But yeah, go
ahead, Chris, and lieber. Yeah,
no more to say. That's plenty. Let's get
into the detail.
Yeah, I'm co working with QRI and a lot
into Active Instruments, and I'm trying
to unify QRI with Active Instruments a
lot. And yeah.
Beautiful. Yeah.
Next slide. Essentially, our outline
of this presentation is going to
essentially walk you through some of the
key ideas of the paper and kind of like
trying to illustrate them or making them
a little bit more intuitive, fairly high
level, although we will actually present
kind of the core argument.
The main thing to point out here next
slide is that the magnetic theories
of consciousness, I guess, like, 20
years ago, they sounded like a total
crackpot type.
Yeah, I've still got a good connection,
so we can give him a moment or two, and
if not, I'll pick up from what was the
crackpot,
see if he reconnects. My gosh, sorry,
Andres, please repeat from crackpot.
Oh, my God. Yeah. Over the last 20
years, however, there's been an
explosion of interest in electromagnetic
theories of consciousness and serious
peer reviewed publications about them,
especially the last ten and then five
years, kind of like a variable
exponential explosion in terms of a
number of serious articles published.
And one of the very kind of key,
amazing kind of contributions that
something like an electromagnetic theory
of consciousness can offer to the
overall ecosystem of philosophy of mind
is that it provides a way to solve
question for how information can be
combined. I mean, essentially, when you
have information distributed, how is it
possible that they can be simultaneously
part of some kind of, like, unified
whole? And electromagnetic theories of
consciousness are just very proud to
say, well, the electromagnetic field is
ontologically unitary, it's already
unified, so there's not much of a
problem here. However, once you
kind of have this unity,
then the question becomes, well, but how
do you actually draw a boundary around
it? So actually, you just traded one
problem for another.
Dig into the details there.
Cool. Shall I take us through the
literature review as context for this?
And then Andreas will come back to kind
of give you the solution that we think
can fit with electromagnetic fields.
So, yeah, the boundary problem. So
binding problem you heard just now into
a first approximation that is, whatever
you think might make up consciousness.
Maybe it's neurons firing. Maybe it's
some sort of magical qualia at the
bottom of the universe. Whatever you
think it is, these small things need to
be bound together to reflect the complex
phenomenology we have. We see lots of
things all at once. Right now, I'm
smelling the flowers outside. I've got
the laptop screen in front of me.
There's lots of stuff happening all at
once in a unified way. So that's the
binding problem. We won't do more on
that here. We'll sort of assume some
familiarity with it. But then the
boundary problem is, well, once you've
got a mechanism that creates the binding
between these lower level entities, why
would that mechanism ever stop? Because
clearly, our awareness, our
phenomenology doesn't go on forever. We
don't know what's happening in Alpha
Centurion. Our awareness is not
unbounded. And as soon as you realize
that you need boundaries around
something, a number of things suddenly
don't quite make sense. So Owen
Schroedinger of physics Fame flagged
this up as one of the things that he
felt was completely unresolved. So
despite his kind of vast intellect and
his contributions elsewhere, he felt
that this puzzle was one of the things
that he described it as. When he turns
his mind to it, everything just
evaporates. None of it makes sense
anymore. He can't get a grip on the
problem. And he described the problem,
as you can see on the screen. He was
saying, why is it that my identity is at
the intermediate level, this kind of
roughly human shaped body?
And you can say, okay, we mostly mean
the central nervous system. But either
way, this broad entity has lots of
smaller things inside it cells, organs,
human bodies, and lots of things above
it cities, states, solar systems,
universes, and so on. Why is our self
consciousness always at this one level?
And if you describe that as a problem to
somebody who's never heard of it before
or never thought of it before this
happened to me just last Friday, they
might say, well, it's obviously just
like the body stops. Like, the skull
stops here, or like, my arm stops here.
Of course, it's not going out to Arthur
Centurion. Why would and it's a very
intuitive, immediate human reaction.
But you probe it a little bit, as
Schrodinger did, and it kind of falls
apart. Because if you're a neuron firing
somewhere in the central nervous system
and you're being initiated by a neuron
in the peripheral nervous system, well,
how do you know to stop binding? How do
you know that there's a boundary that
stops at the edge of the central nervous
system? Or if your fingers are holding
onto a tool and you're getting feedback
from that tool, you're driving a car,
it can feel like you're part of that
car. Where does the system know where
the boundary is because most of these
things that we observe have only
observer dependent boundaries.
If you've got a wheel in a car rolling
along the road, from one perspective,
it looks like the wheel is separate from
the road. But if you're a tiny ant or
something and the car is parked, these
things all may feel like they're one
object. And this was when Schrodinger
turned his mind to this. It puzzled him.
So let's give him the benefit of the
doubt. Let's say that there's something
real to be puzzled through here.
This issue applies both to the example I
started with around building up in small
units. But also if you're a cosmo
panpsychist, you believe that there is
one universal consciousness, and we are
like a god playing with its puppets. In
that case, you still have the same
question because you're still
demarcating boundaries. You just get the
mirror image. We'll mostly focus on the
idea of expanding up from small things
because that's closer to the orthodoxy.
But you can't solve this problem
magically by declaring a single
consciousness. Okay, so Schrodinger
didn't say much more about this. He just
said that this was a puzzle. The first
person we found that really formalized
this and gave it the name boundary
problem was Rosenberg. And it was a
number of pieces, late 90s, early two
thousand s. And he uses the phrase
siller and Cryptus, but it's exactly the
same idea as Schrodinger had. One of
them is, well, why aren't there lots of
small things? I think that might have
been the silla, that might have been the
nine headed monster. And then on the
other hand, what about the things that
we are nested within? And he called that
the Cryptus. And he said, it's very hard
to posit a genuinely robust mechanism
that would stop it in both directions.
You can imagine a reason why lots of
small things get bound together, but why
would the binding stop? And his view
in framing this problem is that no one
had solved it. Winding on to
Andres and I chatting about this last
year and building on some of Qri's
foundational work in this area, we
wanted to know, well, what's happened
since Rosenberg framed this and
Schroding was so puzzled by it. Surely
someone's come up with a few solutions
to it. So Q standard
database driven literature review,
and you've got the details there.
Fairly standard stuff. What we looked
looking across the Scopus database, we
only found five papers that seemed to be
relevant about the boundary problem,
compared to 92 on the binding and 47
on the combination problem. So some of
these related problems, and in our
intro, we kind of went straight from
binding to boundary. They are. So if
you're thinking about one, you really
should be thinking about the other.
Well, that is not reflected in the
literature. We did a bit more puzzling
around. People don't seem to be
referring to this by other names, or
when they are, they haven't solved it
either. So it felt that
there was something worth going at here.
And this is what initiated the paper.
What we did find, though, partly in
those five papers and partly in looking
around, we do find families of possible
solutions. And there's no clear winner.
But maybe philosophy rarely has a clear
winner for anything, so maybe that's an
unreasonable expectation. But there's
definitely open questions for each class
of theories that have been put out there
to solve this problem. So the first of
these loosely termed algorithmic, so
computational causal structure theories,
I'm just trying to summarize them into
one term. Some of the examples there
IIT, of course, very well known global
workspace theory as well. They will
tend to say that things bind together
when they're in a particular pattern.
So you might imagine a database that
references itself or the working memory
of a computer, or as soon as things are
somehow linked together in a causal
sense, in IIT, there's a particular type
of pattern, but nonetheless it's an
abstract informational relationship.
Those papers don't tend to be super
explicit about defining boundaries.
Normally, IIT will normally say, here's
our system, and now let's ask within
that system, where is the highest phi?
They sort of just say, take the
boundaries on that. No one has said,
let's take the whole universe as a
system. The math is already virtually
impossible, even toy systems.
But reading between the lines or reading
some of the other papers around it,
there's something about if you had a hi
fi area surrounded by lots of lo fi
areas, well, it's natural that it's the
bit that's high. And there's this
principle of exclusion that says you
take the highest one in a system, maybe
you have to specify a system before it
makes sense to ask that. And if you took
the highest bit out, somehow you just
remove some of those causal
interconnections that create that
highness. Whatever's left will have a
slightly lower bit of phi, and that is
now where the sort of locus of
consciousness resides. This may well
work, kind of the maths would need
working out, I think Andres and I are
initially skeptical, but because as
best as we can see, no one's really
created complicated maps and discussed
what would happen when you've got
different mixtures of densities that are
shifting over time. What stops it from
being arbitrary? Certainly there are
questions to be had, and we can come
back to this a bit if we want to talk
about it further. But suffice it to say
it's not a guaranteed solution. And
there's one critique that we cite.
There resonance theories,
a link between those and electromagnetic
fields now as well, in that the main
progenitor of these theories. Pam Hunt
would say that the main resonance which
he sees binding happening together in
human consciousness is en fields. So
there are links between these as well,
and maybe the informational patterns are
being encoded in resonance or quantum
entanglement or Em fields. So there can
be links between these as well. The
resonance theory that says that binding
happens when things are in the same
frequency, simple enough, or when they
are close enough, and that becomes a
little bit more debatable. But what does
that really mean, the boundaries? There
is a conceptual solution for this,
which is the slowest shared resonance in
a system, but many of the same issues
apply as with the algorithmic. But
again, if experimenters, it may be
possible to create one that works there
quantum theories entanglement is what
binds it together, at least in some of
them. So what causes two experiences, a
blue cup and the shape of the cup to be
bound together into one? Well, it's that
the blueness and the cupness, I'm
obviously talking at a very high level
of abstraction, but those are somehow
quantum entangled with each other that
would indeed create, to the best of our
physics knowledge today, a kind of
ontologically real binding. And that's
quite an attractive part of the
solution. Well, what would stop those
boundaries? There is the monogamy
principle. Things can only be maximally
entangled up to a certain point, but
there's a very, very open question about
whether that sort of thing would enable
the kind of macro phenomenology we have.
But in the paper we say all of these are
worth exploring, let's keep
investigating. And then there's the one
I started with an instruction like maybe
it's the boundary of the central nervous
system, but hopefully even a small
amount of scrutiny causes that one to
collapse.
And most of these explicitly say that
more work is needed, more math is
needed, and certainly that will be true
of what we're presenting here as well.
What we want to do is add a new one to
this list. And the
inspiration for this is that, well, if
the Em field accounts present a solution
to the binding problem they certainly
believe they do, there's lots of
literature on it, then maybe they
can also provide a solution to the
boundary problem. Given how closely
related they are. When you read those
accounts, they don't quite have it
nailed yet. The most common explanation
they give is a kind of inverse square
law rule where, well, the strength of a
field just becomes so small so quickly.
By the time you're a centimeter out from
the thalamus or by the time you're at
the edges of the skull these fields have
just evaporated into they've decohered.
They're indistinguishable from the
neural noise all around us. That might
be okay if you're okay with a fuzzy
boundary and we'll come on to that in a
SEC. Others motivate a phase transition,
a bit like quantum entanglement or a bit
like the exact resonance of resonance
theories. But those phase transitions
are pretty speculative as well.
So the solution we will
come to and andrews will outline is a
different aspect of em fields. It's not
fuzzy boundaries and it's not a vague
phase transition. It's an entirely
different topological solution which we
argue can solve the problems.
What we think is worth doing, though,
is to make that boundary problem more
explicit. What you've heard both from
Schrodinger and from Rosenberg is this
idea of kind of like why aren't the
cells inside you conscious? Or if they
are conscious, why don't we ever
experience that? And again, going up,
what about cities and families and
things or group chants or football
stadiums, that sort of stuff. And there
is a scholar who argues, based on
resonance theory, that actually when we
are in a group chanting or a group
dancing situation, our consciousness
does in fact move to that level as well.
And it's speculative, but there's much
to be thought about. So to make this
problem more precise, we've got five,
and I'll just give you the one or two
sentences on each. The hard
boundary problem is this
sense that a fuzzy boundary probably
isn't good enough. And let's kind of
explain a bit more why. If you have
something like a wave or the example of
the wheel I gave before touching the
ground or indeed any connection between
any physical atoms, the closer you look
to it, the less obvious it is where it
stops. The boundaries of my skull may
feel very precise to me, but if there
were an alien the size of a solar
system, their ability to perceive this
would most likely just blurs
imperceptibly into its surroundings.
These things feel hard, but they're not
really hard.
At the edges of our awareness, there's
this sense that things might feel fuzzy,
but at some point it just sort of stops,
might feel like it might feel infinite.
There are states of mind where we can
feel an infinite awareness, but probing
that further, it doesn't truly encompass
everything and go on forever. At this
edge. Our assertion is that sometimes
this feels like a hard boundary. And if
it ever sometimes feels like a hard
boundary, then you need some mechanism
that is capable of a hard edge in a way
that these physical phenomena typically
aren't. So that's the hard boundary
definitely happy to drill into more of
any of this or any of the other five if
they're not making enough sense in the Q
A. So lower levels we've covered mean
the great example of this is we know
that when we go to sleep, some part of
our consciousness, at least the bit that
we remember, switches off, yet the brain
remains active. The lower levels
boundary problem could be reinterpreted
as saying why doesn't our awareness just
shift to another part of the brain at
that point? It certainly doesn't seem to
most of the time. Higher level boundary
problem, we've had that from the
beginning. That's why doesn't it go up?
Maybe it does sometimes. Certainly
doesn't normally the private boundary
problem. So this is now, rather than
going down into ourselves or up into the
universe in which we are nested, this is
more take two of those boundaries,
me and you, me and one other person.
Why can we not bridge into each other's
minds, at least not routinely? Those who
claim to do so have struggled to
replicate it and get it into the
mainstream. So this is privacy. There
appears to be some limitation that stops
these mechanisms from connecting with
each other. And yet if it is slowest
shared resonance or if it is highest
informational phi in IIT, why is it not
possible to construct a system in which
the highest phi is now an interconnected
one and our consciousness has collapsed?
Maybe it is possible, and that's just a
technical endeavor we haven't yet
achieved. But either way, there's
something that's challenging about it,
either as a technical barrier or as a
philosophical one. The last one is a
temporal boundary problem because
everything we've said so far is in
space. But the kind of entities and
experiences we're talking about are not
zero time, space based activities.
They have a temporal persistence. So
what is it that puts boundaries around
a micro moment of experience? What is it
that enables us to experience the end of
a note and still retain that idea of the
start of the note and experience them
together? And how does this extend
through broader experiences of the self.
So those are the five puzzles.
Hopefully that's enough of a qualitative
overview so that you know what we're
trying to solve at least. And if I hand
back over to Andrews now, he will give
you an entirely new solution to these
puzzles. Yes.
Next slide. Going a little bit broader
too, in that what Chris just talked
about is kind of the criteria for the
boundary problem, kind of like breaking
down the boundary problem into
subcomponents. And then there's also,
more broadly, things that you would want
out of a theory of consciousness. And so
the solution to the boundary problem
ideally will also, in a sense, satisfy
these constraints. And these constraints
are framing variance nominated
phenomenalism and no strong emergence.
Next slide. So framing variance
essentially can be recapariance.
The fact that whatever structure is
giving rise to the boundary shouldn't in
a way, be frame specific, shouldn't just
depend on how you're looking at an
object. It should be kind of like an
intrinsic objective property of the
object that if you move it around, it
shouldn't, in principle, be changing in
that way. Next slide.
Non epiphenomenalism. For those who are
not familiar with the term, this is the
idea that for a particular conscious
physical system, there corresponds an
experience, but that there's no causal
influence from that conscious experience
back into the system. And there's like,
various ways of kind of trying to ground
the question of, hey, why is
epiphenomenalism not the case? There's
kind of differences in emphasis by each
of these questions, but they're roughly
pointing in the same direction. One
important question is how is it possible
that we can talk in detail about our
experience, but the way we actually
framed it in the paper that we find the
most compelling is how was evolution
able to recruit? Coherent, globally
bound states. If they're not causally
significant, if they're not causally
useful, it would just be an
extraordinary coincidence that it just
happens to happen simultaneously along
with something that seems to be
computationally significant and
encompass a whole lot of information at
the same time. Next slide.
And then we also have no strong
emergence. There's this quote from David
that says, the Lagrangian of the
standard model does not break down
inside one's own skull. Meaning we want
the laws of physics to apply universally
to whatever explanation space we come up
with that we don't want to introduce
special cases or say like, oh, there's
like a special different field in the
brain, or anything of the sort. We want
to have a homogeneous set
of physics that as simple as it
gets, as mainstream as it gets in terms
of appealing to standard physics. Next
slide. So, yeah, the overarching
solution and explanation space, that is
electromagnetic field topology. So,
first of all, I will walk you through in
what way this explanation space
satisfies the kind of like three
constraints that I provided. And then
Chris is going to explain how it
addresses each of the sub problems.
Next slide.
So, yeah, next one.
Yeah, if you actually kind of look at
these amazing reconstructions of the
electromagnetic field of stellar bodies,
you would see that nothing trivial about
it. There's like all of this incredible
complexity and richness in structure.
A lot of it is very counterintuitive,
not something that you would see with a
naked eye. You require superimposing,
a lot of pictures from the different
regions of the spectrum to kind of get a
picture of what's going on in the
electromagnetic field. And yeah, it has
kind of these elongated, weird plasma
tubes and circular structures and loops
and so on. So it's a very structurally
rich environment. Next slide.
And the way in which something
like the topology of that field will
satisfy the criteria that wet line is as
follows. So if you look at the
electromagnetic field of the sun,
sometimes this phenomena called magnetic
reconnection happens. And this is
actually responsible for solar flares
and kernel mass ejections. It has to do
with when plasma tubes that are the
electromagnetic confinement structures
touch with each other and so they can
open up and spray plasma into the outer
space. The key thing to point about
here is that this is actually a
topological change to the field. It's
not just any kind of physical change
when you have a solar flare coronal mass
ejection that is the effect of a
macroscopic gigantic topological
transformation. What this slide is
trying to get at is that whether a
system experienced magnetic reconnection
or not will not depend on your frame of
reference. And the very simple reason is
that Lorentz transforms simply squeeze
and stretch, but they never actually
reconnect or cut or add
any kind of topological change. In other
words, a Lorentz transform will leave a
topological event untouched. So in that
sense okay, like topology as an
explanation space for why this
is framing variant, it definitely fits
the bill. Next slide.
Importantly, too, in the brain, we also
can tackle the question of, like, in
what way the field is not epiphenomenal.
There's a lot of research on local field
potentials in the which are little
microscopic electric oscillations, and
they do seem to actually have causal
effects on the activity of neurons. In
other words, people might believe, in a
sense, that, hey, brainwaves are kind of
just a reflection of neural activity.
But the thing that something like
transcranial magnetic stimulation makes
clear is that on top of that, they
actually feed back into the probability
for neurons to fire, especially the
probability for neurons to fire in
synchrony or in a state of coherence.
In other words, the actual causal
structure of electromagnetic field and
how it connects to neural activity is
this dual causal arrow where neural
activity influences local field
potentials, neural activity influences
activity via synapse.
Yeah, we've been the victim of the
connection. Again, let's hope it comes
back as quickly as it did last time.
Yes, there's a lot to say,
but I won't.
Hopefully you got some harsh questions
written down as we've been taking you
through it. Yeah, just enough people who
are listening in the discussion will
look at some questions, so please feel
free to write anything.
It personally, I'm curious whether the
awareness is going to be the light of
the sun, the heat of the sun, the
ejection, the loop structure,
the birth and death of the star.
Yeah. If the
idea that you'll see here stands, then
you've got the idea that a closed
topological pocket of electromagnetic
field, that's where awareness can take
place. That's where a first person
perspective, a kind of a locus, can
exist. But what it's aware of? Well,
that's an entirely different question.
And if there are pockets like that,
we're not asserting in this paper that
the sun has these it's such a complex
entity. It's very possible, but that is
a different but if to the extent they
are there, what on Earth would be
experienced within it? That's a
different thing. The content problem,
it's not just for YouTubers, it's also
for conscious systems. But yeah,
you've bound it all together, you've
delimited a boundary topologically and
then about what? And so what?
Yeah,
let me pick up a bit while we're while
we're waiting for him to come in.
And there's really growing kind of
neuroscience and biological evidence for
downward causation from electromagnetic
fields in the brain. And all we really
do in this paper is acknowledge that
research literature exists and say, and
therefore, it's possible for fields to
be non epipenomenal. We don't get into
the specifics of it, but they've been
shown in memory formation. They've been
shown in the olfactory bulb for your
smells. They've appeared all over the
place. Andres, you're back.
Just making the case for non
epiphenomenal fields in the brain. Oh,
fantastic. Beautiful. Yeah. Sorry about
that. Hopefully, it doesn't happen
again. Okay. Next slide.
Yeah. And think about
the immense causal power that a
topological change in the field has in
cosmological terms, like these billions
of tons of plasma being ejected just
because of otherwise epiphenomenal
magnetic reconnection. It's like, no,
actually, topological transformations
are really significant at a massive,
massive scale. Next slide?
Yeah. Next one. Just showing
kind of how ridiculously powerful this
can be. Yeah. And importantly,
too, the actual fact that
you get an enclosure with a topological
transformation in a medium also gives
you this capacity to essentially have
holistic behavior. This is one of the
things that, to me, was kind of the most
exciting about this explanation space.
The moment you can close field lines or
do a top formation, waves will be
confined. Some kinds of waves can be
confined within a topological pocket.
When you have confinement of waves,
then you have resonant modes. And when
you have resonant modes, then you have
this very fantastic effect where the
whole shape of an object essentially is
expressed in the way every part of the
object is vibrating,
in which case, essentially, you have
this reason why evolution would recruit
these topological objects is because it
actually allows organisms to behave as a
unit. So I think, yeah, that might be a
very key piece of the puzzle for
epiphenomenalism. Next slide. These are
just kind of like some sketches of some
of the kinds of boundaries that, in
principle, you may have in the
electromagnetic field and what kind of
binding in consciousness they might
correspond to. But you don't have to
just speculate. The really exciting
thing here is that you can actually play
with simulations of the electromagnetic
field to try to make sense of the
topological transformations that happen
in it. So the next following slides we
can just go through them fairly quickly
are essentially resonant modes of an
empty cavity, electromagnetic resonance
modes of an empty cube cavity, where the
left side is the electric field and the
right side is the magnetic field.
The website where you can check this is
called Falstad.com EMBOX.
And the thing that it kind of really
neatly shows is how the magnetic field
sometimes get this closed looping
structure. Next slide. Yeah, just go
through them, maybe like 5 seconds for
each of them. And it
also allows you to essentially look at
what happens when you stack some of
these resonant modes. And some
combinations, linear combinations of
these resonant modes create intricate
eddings and loops and twists that. Loop
around and create this topological
boundary very fleeting. It has to do
with the frequency of oscillation of the
electric field, how many times per
second you're going to get this looping
structure. But the fact that yeah, you
can show there's some topologically
closed objects that appear there is
quite remarkable. And overall, the idea
here would be that well, something like
this is happening in the brain and the
brain is actually recruiting these
looping architectures. All right, I'll
hand it over to Chris.
Thank you very much. Yes, we've seen
that electromagnetic fields can form
closed loops and people have used that,
some of the sites in the paper around
people trapping knots of light. And it
just kind of really remarkable things
happening at the edge of sort of room
temperature state physics. Really
incredible stuff. We know that in
principle, these fields are capable of
downward causation in massive contexts
like the sun, but also in very real
human brain settings. So conceptually,
and we know that topologies in general
are framing variants. So we've got those
things in place, we've got boundaries
that satisfy those various features that
we wanted. We don't know exactly how
they occur in the human brain. All we're
presenting is a conceptual solution that
those things are possible. But what we
do say is, well, what would such a
solution look like to those five
boundary problems that we just
described? So taking them one by one,
or rather yeah, taking them as a group.
Let's first say what in such a theory,
the first person perspective, that kind
of phenomenal awareness, the what it's
likeness that we experience in a very
normal everyday sense, what could that
reflect, what could that correspond to
in such a model? And there are others,
but we'll give one example and use that
to walk through the problems. So we
would say that once you've got a closed
topology and it may well require the
time dimension for it to be properly
ontologically closed and at that point
em energy of that specific spectra, the
same spectra that's making up the
boundary can't pass through it or not.
That's the whole point about the closed
loop. Other things might pass through
it, sound wave might pass through it.
But nonetheless, for the entities that
we're interested in, it is closed to
itself. And that's where we can get this
hard boundary. There may be lots of
these being created in the brain. The
brain is absolutely chock a block with
different bits of em generating
underlying phenomena. So it's certainly
plausible that some of them are closed.
We don't know. For this to be true,
there must be at least one. But it's
plausible that if there's one, there's
probably several. So you've got several
of these. By definition they are non
overlapping, the boundaries cannot
overlap, but they could well be multiple
at the same time. One at the front, one
at the back could be all over the place.
It's probable though, that only a subset
would be continually recreated in a
stable manner because the fact that
these fields can have downward
causation, they can do useful things.
Some of the sites in the paper about
information processing point to some of
the nonlinearities you can achieve
through wave and field based resonant,
mode based computations which may well
have benefits from an information
processing perspective. So in some cases
these will be continually recreated.
Only one of them, because they cannot
overlap, only one of them can enclose,
let's call it an immediate memory model
as a conceptual point, not committing to
what exactly that might mean.
We suspect these wouldn't last very long
and they probably don't extend over the
whole brain, but who knows? Regardless,
it would vary from period to period.
Other field theories might have other
ways of recruiting this concept for
solving the boundary problem, but let's
walk this one through and see what it
looks like as a response to those five
things. So what we're saying is this
closed topological pocket that is kind
of axiomatically the same as a first
person awareness. When you've got that,
you've got something that is capable of
both binding together those micro bits
of experience and presenting them within
a boundary so they have some unified
ontology. So one
by one, and I think this is our last
slide, the hard boundary, well, that
comes from what we've been talking
about. Energy of the same spectra can't
pass through the closed loop. So that
happens quite naturally, a bit like with
the field solution to binding. This is
something you almost get for free as a
result of using that lower levels and
higher levels well, because only
one of them, because of the non
overlapping point, because only one of
them can include the immediate memory
model, which is crucial for the next
bit, then you can't have lower levels
and higher levels. There may well be
mind dust at those levels which is this
kind of lovely evocative concept. There
may well be flashes of tiny bits of
awareness that kind of they never repeat
the patterns just gone for it. There's
nothing that links it into future
versions of itself, just gone. The
universe may be replete with these
things. It's certainly got plenty of
electrons in it. Why not plenty of these
things? Who knows? But there's only one
closed pocket that maybe I'll come back
to four that can enclose this immediate
memory module. That's crucial because
it's what creates a temporal boundary
that in any possible sense could reflect
what we experience day to day. Because
these tiny if you
think of these 4D pockets,
if one pocket were to last long enough
to encompass, say, a whole day's worth
of your experience, it's almost
impossible for it to vary enough without
breaking to actually contain all the
types of complex phenomena we experience
during the day. Which is why we think
it's much more likely they persist for a
short period of time, but nonetheless,
our experiences of things persisting for
longer. Now, the micro level
persistence, why is it nonzero? Because
if something is infinitesimally small,
it probably doesn't help us. If
something is the equivalent of a
geometric point, no matter how many of
them you put together in a physical
setting, you're not going to create a
line. We want some non zero duration.
Well, we've got that for free because
the closed pocket has this 4D
ontological presence. That's fine. How
would you get but it may be really
short, far shorter than we experience
even this sentence. So what ties that
together? Well, because it encloses each
millisecond to millisecond, it
recreates. Each one is a different piece
of awareness. They are not in any way
ontologically linked to each other,
they are each separate. But because each
one encloses the memory module, which is
just an information processing thing,
you can encode memory and pen and paper.
There's nothing magical about this. By
referencing it, it knows what was just
there before, and that can create we
could call it an illusion if you want.
Whether that matters is a much more
philosophical point. But you create this
pseudo time arrow, you have unified
insight, because that's what fields do.
They unify the insight in all the things
that make it up. No information is lost.
It is all bound together. So now you've
got the recent past and then you've got
the bit before that from the previous
pocket, and the bit before that and the
bit before that. So it's all bound into
each individual present. As short as
it may be, it has the sense that it's
something bigger. Now, in terms of the
macro level, days, years between
interruptions, this is one where we are
far more philosophically relaxed. It may
well be that there is no kind of
profound sense in which these things are
the same entity. It's maybe a ship of
theseus type concept, and it's all
linked together by some fairly weak long
term memory. And are we really the same
person as we were a week ago, a year
ago? We're far less philosophically
concerned about that than we are by the
micro level and the meter level. But
either way, the solutions are the
classic personal identity solutions,
which have been gone over plenty of
times. If you'll give us another five
minutes before questions, we'd love to
share some more kind of speculative
thoughts with you. Getting a thumbs up.
Wonderful. In which case, over to Andres
for some fun, thought provoking stuff.
Well, awesome. Yeah, I mean,
it's just kind of like this deeper
question. And don't wait for me if my
internet runs out for a second. But
essentially, how does this influence,
for example, beliefs of personal
identity? Next slide. I think once
you start seeing the universe as a field
and with maybe like fleeting topological
pockets on it, that actually very
significantly informs these classic
questions in philosophy like who are
you? And do you continue to exist from
one moment to the other and indeed the
other sheep of the sea's? Is there any
kind of metaphysical endearing ego, so
to speak? And I actually think that each
of these views of personal identity
could actually be reinterpreted in terms
of claims about the field and field
topology. So something like closed
individualism. This is the belief that
you start existing when you're born,
stop existing when you die, or maybe you
go to heaven. But the point is that
you're kind of a separate self that
endures over time that is different than
other selves. Here we would want to
find some kind of enduring sheath or
enduring nested architecture that even
though maybe each moment of awareness
might be its own topological pocket,
maybe there's some kind of higher order
topological unity that does carry over a
person's lifetime. That would be a
possible way of raifying in an actual
significant physical way the sense of
identity over time. Of course,
completely speculative. It would be a
matter of actually finding it in the
field. But that's how you could, I
think, Steel men this notion. Next
slide, then probably the most compatible
and easy to justify view here would be
empty individualism, that every moment
of experience is ontologically
different. And again here that would be
possible because we would have these
fleeting hard boundaries in the
spacetime continuum. And as a
consequence, you can look at the block
universe and say, okay, there's a 40
pocket there, there's a 40 pocket over
there. And wherever you see a 40 pocket,
that is going to be a subject of
experience. And any actual continuity
between moments of experience are either
just causal or kind of illusory
constructed with the memory module, as
Chris was suggesting. And then next
slide and then finally open
individualism, there's this view that we
are all one consciousness. We're all
Krishna at the bottom layer, so to
speak. Well, the way we could justify
this within the topological account is
that, well, actually at the deepest
ontological level, we're all the field,
which just happened to be on a given
point in time segmentation of that field
that prevents information propagation
with other regions of the field. So in
this case, kind of the topological
segmentation would actually be more of
an epistemological boundary than it
would actually be an ontological
boundary. It's like the idea that deep
down actually we are the field. It's
just that how the field knows itself is
constrained by its topology in which
case, yeah, it's another way of still
meaning we're all one consciousness in a
very physically grounded way. And,
yeah, I think that's it. Unless I put
anything else in the next slide oh,
yeah, just the last kind of like
speculation here is, well, okay, if you
are this topological pocket in the field
electromagnetic field, how can
you in a sense, take a look at that
pocket and then reconstruct what the
experience feels like. And here perhaps
like a fun thought experiment that you
could make is thinking about what it
would be like to be a photon trapped
kind of within a hall of mirrors.
There's this article I wrote, 2018 about
how to replicate a hyperbolic space
using just double mirrors and
gradient index optics. And essentially
within that structure that has those
properties, a photon would have no way
of telling the fact that it is not in
hyperbolic space. In other words, the
index of refraction of a container would
present itself as the actual geometry of
the space from within. So in our brain,
presumably, the actual way in which the
local field potentials are stitched
together and the relative index of
refraction could potentially give rise
to really arbitrary possible internal
geometrics. Where there's the illusion
that you're in a space, whether it's in
hyperbolic space, in spherical space,
some irregular geometry, all of those
could be emulated with this paradigm.
And that may go a little bit a long way
in actually explaining some of the most
exotic experiences that people can have,
which usually would challenge kind of
theories of consciousness. Here there's
a way of stitching them together to
explain them. And I think yeah, the last
slide, I believe. Yeah. So this
is just illustrating that point, I think
this is it. And we
can leave this up on the screen. This is
just where we would go next with it.
But this seems like a good point to stop
and hear your thoughts.
Awesome. Great presentations.
Well, Bernie, would you like to give
first reflection and I'll write down
some questions and look in the live
chat? Yeah, sure.
I've been thinking a lot about similar
stuff like this recently, and the
paper presents how the functional
theories have the problem of
arbitrariness. So, for example, with
Markov blanket Markov blankets, that
could be the case when there's Markov
blankets as ontological observers. And I
was thinking that maybe unifying
this with the Marko blanket paradigm is
that the mark of blanket that on the
physical level is implemented using
this topological pocket is the conscious
mark of blackend. So it's how you were
referring the mark of black and solves
the content problem, while the
topological boundary solves all the
other problems. Like objective.
Maybe.
Yeah, no, that's something very quick to
mention. Obviously, we're in the active
inference institute podcast. I mean,
absolutely. One thing to mention is that
our perspective is not in itself
necessary or is not necessary and
sufficient actually to satisfy the code
that we have specified. However,
we actually think it's very likely that
topological pockets in the
electromagnetic field do behave as mark
of blankets. And so it is a way in which
you can actually interface these
different paradigms where we would be
saying that at the implementation level
can then realize the minimization of
free energy at the algorithmic level.
However, we would be saying, and maybe
this would be a little bit of a twist or
a nontrivial implication, that if you
were to simulate a hierarchically
structured mark of blanket system in a
computer, it could very well be from a
certain abstraction, be minimizing free
energy, but it wouldn't be able to solve
the boundary problem. In other words,
it is sort of like there is a
significant overlap, but there are some
slight places of a divergence where you
might say, hey, a market blanket is
actually not enough because it doesn't
give you the implementation level
explanation for how you get boundaries.
Chris, if you want to add anything.
Yeah, I mean, just to agree with that,
I think this is if you go back to Mars,
three levels around kind of what
substrate we
haven't discussed anything here about
the algorithms that are actually taking
place on or kind of within the brain
that would ultimately get incorporated
into the Em field. Clearly you need that
stuff as well. None of this makes any
contribution to solving these more
content problems of consciousness or how
we make inferences about the world, how
we respond to those. What it does say is
that if there are algorithms that solve
those problems, and there are some good
candidates out there, including yours,
they need to be implemented
or they need to reflect back to a field
for it to become part of someone's
unified macrophenomenological
experience. If you did some sort of feed
forward in Silico version of this, or
you did it, you implemented the
algorithm using rocks, just lots and
lots of rocks laid out forever like that
wonderful xkcd example,
that is not going to create a bound
first person perspective anywhere.
Well, a lot to say about that,
certainly Markov blankets. And just to
define it on a Bayesian graph, so the
map not the territory. The Markov
blanket is the set of nodes upon which
two other sets of nodes are
conditionally independent. And that's a
purely topological statement. It doesn't
matter how far if there even is a
spatial association or temporal
association, it doesn't matter the
distance, which is to say the geometry,
but rather the blanket is a purely
topological statement. And that's what,
among other things, we've been exploring
with Chris Fields in the physics as
information processing and this question
about the topology of communication for
bounded observers, and as we kind of
alluded to with that content problem,
the topology of communication is,
to use a geometric metaphor, it's
orthogonal to the content. You could
have two people on the phone sharing
different things. You could have a video
file with different contents. And so
there's really a lot of layers that come
into play. And so, I think, from an
instrumentalist view, I read your paper
as a call for the introduction of
topology into what is often only modeled
as geometric. A call for the integration
of electromagnetism rather than a
reliance on one or the other. Of course,
as introduced from the outset, a
pluralism these are not exhaustive nor
exclusive accounts, and we don't know
what the scope of the possible
intelligences and awarenesses are.
So from a research perspective, if not
beyond, why would we want to limit when
we're not only interested in
understanding the properties of any
given system as we see it today?
Any thoughts where I can read a question
in the Chat? Oh,
that sounds great. Turnkey Tyranny
writes, how does topology show up
phenomenologically?
Yeah, this is an excellent, excellent
question. I'm happy to take it. Andrews
do you want to go back to your notes?
We've got that page of notes in there.
Sure, let's do that.
Because I've asked a very similar
question of Andres, and these sort of
notes is what resulted in his attempts
to explain it to me. Let me take yes,
this is very speculative, but one
wonderful resource, I think, hopefully I
think is wonderful, very worth trying
out is we made a series of
guided meditations about phenomenology.
It's not really kind of like for the
sake of spirituality. It's more for the
sake of exploring phenomenology with
meditation. The last one is called the
phenomenology of ontology. And that one
helps you, in a sense, get a sense of
how beliefs about the narrative reality
reality, of course,
different to believe that
electromagnetic field or you're an
electromagnetic feels or
in a specific version of materialism or
something like that. So very different
ontologies can give rise to very
different feelings. And so there's
definitely the worry that, well, if you
think a lot about the electromagnetic
field, aren't you maybe just
interpreting your sensations within that
paradigm, but it's kind of like you're
overfeeding on top of it. But in
a sense, I would argue that actually
it's the other way around. With
something as generic and structured as
electromagnetic field, you can, I think,
in principle, explain the phenomenology
of any ontology. Like, why does it feel
like, for example, that you can
kind of merge with the cosmos or
something like that? Why does it feel
like you can become one with everything
in meditation, let's say in various
meditation states? Well, with something
like the topological explanation for the
boundary problem, the way we might
interpret that is as the vanishing of
internal boundaries. And so there is a
significant difference between a global
boundary, which is what we focused on,
the overall kind of the macroscopic
division that says whether you're inside
or outside your experience. But
something that the electromagnetic field
also affords and gives us as kind of
part of its rich structure is the
possibility of internal boundaries as
well, which would be not boundaries that
wrap around a 4D object, but rather
lower dimensional boundaries like
meeting points or convergence points of
the field lines within the pocket. And
so in this account, whenever you have
the sensation of solidity, the feeling
of, well, I am here, you're there, or
there's a boundary between us, that
boundary would essentially be an
internal boundary, would be a region of
the field while the field lines converge
or they align,
but it's only along a certain cross
section. Meaning that actually your
experience is still fully unified. You
can still go from one point to the other
across a perceived barrier because
they're still part of the whole
experience, they're still connected. In
other words, with this kind of data
structure, we can arrive at kind of like
a lot of phenomenological details and
trying to explain them from that
perspective. And I think it's going to
be an enormous program in the long term
involving physicists and mathematicians
and exotic states of consciousness to
say like, okay, that particular feature
of experience that happens on such and
such substance in such meditation state,
how does that map into the
electromagnetic field? And I think we
will very likely find a lot of non
trivial connections with that sort of
paradigm.
Chris, any thoughts on that?
Just to make the link to some
of the diagrams on the page, which is if
you've got these non 4D closed
boundaries, but other types of
boundaries, the other types of shapes
Andrews was talking about, the drawings
on the page are just examples of some of
those. As Andrew
said, it's not really part of the
solution, but it's part of imaginatively
exploring where else it might go. So if
you've got feature binding, which know
I'm seeing a cup and the cup is both
blue and cup shaped, that's feature
binding. And then the phenomenological
binding is my whole experience being
unified. You can imagine feature binding
putting the blueness and the cupness
together. That might be something that
happens along one of these types of
internal boundaries. It might not. It
might be that that can be done purely
through informational associations.
We're kind of agnostic on that. But
what's interesting about a 4D topology
is within it you can have lots of other
complicated topologies provided they are
not closed along the fourth dimension,
because then you sort of created another
little mini bit of bit of awareness.
Oh, Bernie. Go ahead. Yeah, I'll jump
back to the other page. Yeah, I wanted
to say something else not related to
this exact question. So if you have
ended it, maybe. I'll well, in that
case, actually, I'll mention one last
thing about how electromagnetic field
may be related to phenomenology. A very
specific thing that happens on
psychedelics, and especially something
like DMT is that you may end up having
different regions of your experience,
have the exact same texture, and have
the feeling of synchronization between
them. And when that happens, they sort
of become the same object, just like
spatially distributed. The way I
interpret this is whenever the exact
same wave equation applies to two
regions of your experience and waves can
propagate from one region to the other
that actually feels like they're the
same object. So one kind of, like,
natural way in which regions of your
phenomenal world might be segmented out
into phenomenal objects is by confining
how waves can move within the world
simulation. And whenever you have what
feels like a bound object in your world
simulation that I think is highly,
highly related to waves being able to
smoothly travel within that object but
not outside of that object, some kind of
wave confinement is happening. I'll add
in one more, of course, fun and
speculative thought, which is the
aboutness the content of what this
computation or what this process is
unfolding. The aboutness itself can be
structure learning. And so even for a
fixed electromagnetic topology, you can
have variable informational topology.
Case in point, the von Neumann computer,
the CPU architecture.
Electromagnetically is not changing
topologically. We don't need to reroute
the telephone connections for there to
be different messages that spread. And
so there's a lot of richness in the
space you've sketched or surveyed,
because even for a fixed topology, we
might be able to do compositional
binding like blue and cup.
And then now we add in a dynamic,
multiscale topological unfolding,
and then that may connect to different
frequencies of, for example,
measurements in the EEG, which are
really only picking up the synchrony in
the outer shell, which might
actually play a role. It's not like the
skull matters. You could have a skull
removed. It's not the scalp. It's not
your hair. It's not necessarily the
meninge. But what is it? Well, maybe
it's something that's infotainment
that reflects kind of different regimes
of attention that actually does happen
to correspond, but it's also localized,
and that's that interplay with
individuality and oneness that
works like Wilbur's, no boundary point
towards, but then you got to come back
from no boundary because that sentence
has to end.
Bernie. Yeah. I wanted to mention
that in relation to the ongoing curves
on the physics and information
processing that Chris Fields is hosting
is one construct that Chris Fields is
using in his papers with Michael and
Paul is the notion of topological
quantum neural networks and topological
quantum field theories. So it might be
that those are the
information processing in this kind of
topological maps as well that you've
mentioned. Daniel, the grounding
for that or how Michael Levin is talking
about how bioelectricity is a glue for
the various subsystems in the brain.
Or I've seen some recent paper that was
pretty late.
I found out recently, which I'm pretty
surprised at just recently, that there
is a whole field of people that are
really trying to apply quantum field
theory on the brain. And there was one
paper on memory formation. So how
you, Chris, talked about memory in terms
of the electromagnetic field that might
be also great, like pointer. So I'm just
putting out different people and
papers that I think might be
interconnectable with this work. Yeah.
One interesting thing, and you reflected
it in your literature review is when
people think about quantum and cognitive
systems, the ORC, or and other
frameworks often are considering quantum
as being electronic scale. And therefore
a quantum theory of cognition or
consciousness would entail some kind of
relationship between the way that
electrons and photons behave and then
some difference that makes a difference
at the biological level. And in
a way, what we've been exploring with
Chris Fields and others is like a bypass
where it's like, no, the quantum
formalism, quantum topology, quantum
information simply and plainly describes
cognitive processes where order matters.
Now, there may or may not be effects
associated with differences that make a
difference at the electronic scale, but
we don't need that in order to use
superposition and all of these different
effects that empirically are the case in
cognitive systems. We're not waiting for
some new mechanistic insight. It'd be
cool to find out. But what you've
presented is not waiting
for a different kind of thing to exist.
So I'm curious, what experiments or what
are the unique experiments that
you feel like would give a resounding
feeling on what you're talking about?
Yeah, happy to take it on. So one
kind of, like, very awesome research
lead, and then I'll explain what a
research paradigm will look like. But
essentially, first of all, a very
powerful lead is meditative cessations.
So one of the most insane chapters in
mastering the core teachings of the
Buddha by Daniel Ingram is the one
called The Three Doors, where he
describes the phenomenology of
experiencing a peak meditation state
that's called a cessation. Where you
blink out of reality for a second or
well, for a subsecond moment, but you
just blink out fully and then you get
reconstituted. And when you get
reconstituted, it tends to be a very
blissful, very rejuvenating type
experience. But the thing he highlights
in that article is what it feels like to
be really close to a cessation. And it
actually depends on what type of
cessation it is. There's roughly, like,
three ways in which it can happen. But
the mind blowing thing about that essay,
that chapter is he essentially describes
different topologies of attention and
awareness that may arise where in these
moments, close to a cessation, he says,
well, in one of those you become kind of
a taurus. And the taurus flips the
inside and an outside and it twists
around and then it cancels out and
compresses and then you vanish. And then
there's like, another variety where you
become a cone, and then all of your
attention gets concentrated in the point
of the coin of the cone, and then that
twists around and then vanishes. So
there's like this reliable,
very exotic kind of like topological
transformations that can happen to your
attention and awareness. And our guess
would be that, well, a cessation, an
actual kind of full vanishing, might be
related to the topological pocket that
your brain is generating, essentially
opening up. So that in some maybe
nontrivial way, the actual boundary
between inside and outside gets
dissolved for a fraction of a second,
then it gets reconstituted. But
something really special happens in that
moment that allows for deep insight or
something along the lines or relieving a
lot of internal stress, maybe like a
coronal mass ejection. There might be
something going on at the topological
level. Now, in terms of kind
of like, further, more sophisticated
research paradigms, the thing that we're
looking into, there's a lot more to be
unpacked and developed here, but is what
kind of electromagnetic resonant modes
that can supervene on particular graphs,
whether we're talking about the
Connectum or whether we're talking about
the geometric eigen modes. More recent
work where you model the entire cortex
as a geometric surface, and then you
apply neural field theory to that.
Well, all of that works so far.
Essentially, what it focuses on is
oscillations in the electric field
without modeling the magnetic field. So
I would suspect that many of the
Connectum harmonics or geometric eigen
modes may be physically unrealizable
simply because the magnetic field lines
may collide with each other. So some of
those may not be possible. But one of
the crazy, fascinating, unusual
predictions that may come out of our
whole paradigm is that once we have a
really good mapping of what resonant
modes arise in the brain on
different states of consciousness, we
would predict that a when you're fully
awake, normally conscious, there will be
a very central, big topological loop
inside you that whenever you're, let's
say, in deep sleep, you might see a kind
of mind dust. You might see lots of tiny
little pockets. And maybe when you're in
an ecstatic experience, like deep
meditation, it may do something else.
Like the particular resonant modes there
may create open field lines that don't
form a loop. So that is like the sort of
crazy, very novel type of prediction,
or at least research paradigm that this
enables. That's really
cool. Chris, anything out of that?
Yeah, just to draw the link between the
fourth bullet here and what Andres is
setting out. I don't think any of this
is there are some toy bits of modeling
you could do that could increase
confidence one way or another. But in
terms of an actual experimental
prediction, you would need to combine
this with some theory of which
bits of the brain are doing this. So if
Ward and Guevara are right that it's the
thalamus that's doing this stuff, we
would expect to see around the thalmus a
closed pocket. And it should be
possible. In principle, this is probably
billions of pounds worth of effort. But
to model the thalamus and the
surrounding bits enough, and you can
find out if there would actually be a
closed pocket, if there would be one.
In theory, you can see roughly where it
would be. Obviously, it moves around a
bit, but it's normally around here you
then should be able to I don't know if
ethical consent is even possible for
something like this, but disrupt that
with a very, very targeted external Em
source. Think transcranial stimulation,
but just laser precise. If we've
now broken the bid around the thalamus
but left everything else more or less
untouched, we predict if warding of our
plus us is correct, we predict that your
first personal awareness would blink
out. Like deep sleep, like anesthesia
like a meditative cessation. If we're
wrong, or the combination of us is
wrong, then you will still be conscious,
but you might just experience something
really bloody weird. But your contents
have changed, not the actual container
of consciousness hasn't blinked in and
out, and then you could apply that to
other bits of the brain wherever you
think there's. Our other prediction is
that it must be enclosing the immediate
memory model, but we're unsure exactly
where that is as well. That is also an
outstanding research question.
It feels like doable in our lifetimes,
I think, but none of this is give us ten
grand and we'll do it this summer. None
of it is that easy. Yeah,
very interesting. And Neuroimaging
already utilizes electromagnetic
measurements and there are things that
currently are described within a
biomolecular paradigm, like, for
example, changes in effective
connectivity between different regions
of the brain. Well, there's already a
tract, let's just say, between certain
brain regions. And so maybe if
the action potentials traveling down
that 100 lane highway are
aligned, then it's going to be like this
rippling em continuity. Whereas if they
were totally disarrayed along that
track, then you wouldn't have
those two regions contained. But it'd be
like kind of like two regions, like
blowing smoke rings at each other if
they had enough synchrony to push
through the trouble and the friction
such that there was a pocket that was
able to you squirt hot water
into a cold pool. There's ways
to angle it and do it in all of the
combinations of viscosity that it just
diffuses instantly. There's also ways
where there would be a high temperature
toroidal form that could pass through a
colder media because it maintains a
topological boundary. A lot of these
things are again described anatomically
or molecularly or electronically,
but the duality between electronics
and magnetism is not contentious.
So there may be a lot of phenomena that
could be revisited, and I don't
know whether that would provide indirect
evidence with what we already know or
suggest new plausible experiments, but
it's an approach.
Yeah. Welcome it. And thanks, Bernie as
well for the pointers towards, like,
Chris Fields and Michael Levin. I may
come back to you for the QFT on memory
formation in case I've spotted some
stuff on that, but I'm not sure I've
spotted the one it sounded like you were
referring to. So yeah, it's an exciting
sort of research. Yeah. One last
connection there with active inference
is you have the electronic and the
magnetic fields influencing each other.
That's the basis of what philosophers
might consider in terms of this
epipenomenalism or not question.
And if we had an active inference
situation of two songbirds, the active
states of one become the sensory of the
other. So if they were just passing
messages every single time step to each
other, then they would both be engaged
in their own blanketed perception on the
inbound and action selection on the
outbound. And so they could basically be
in this continual oscillatory
relationship with causal efficacy both
ways. Again, or you could design a
situation where the causal efficacy only
flowed one way. But the point is, this
is a topological approach that lets us
explore that in a way that isn't only
appealing to molecular or material
phenomena and then leaving the whole
question, which is the whole question of
the informational. And the closure and
the binding. Leaving all those to be
resolved by slicing and dicing with a
scalpel. Which is not even a
viable option as far as we already
understand.
Bernie and then the authors,
what are your closing thoughts or how
would you suggest that people get in the
game or what should they do with their
own topologies?
Maybe I could note that Andres could
expand on, if he wants to know.
Synthetic valence and neuroanalink.
Well, yeah,
STB introduced by Mike in 2015 on
Principalia about the correspondence
respondents between imagery
of an object for
many years now. You can see a 2020
presentation about it and there's many
more content about it. But the main
idea, the way it would actually work out
here is the regions of the
topologically closed field that behave
like a smooth field may potentially
correspond to a very blissful
experience. So I'm very optimistic of
the potential of okay, like something
like a peak blissful experience, peak
five meodmt experience or something like
that. It would probably, I suspect,
have like a very internally simplified
topology where the geometry is as smooth
as possible. So that's kind of like an
interesting prediction or angle on all
of this, I think. Yeah. Maybe to
wrap up, I would say that we would
enormously welcome anybody who is
technically savvy for doing
interesting simulations of the
electromagnetic field. I mean, we're
doing ourselves some really interesting
experiments and in combination with
classical neural networks, but anybody's
kind of like the intersection between
machine learning electromagnetic fields
and simulations and statistics,
machine learning essentially that kind
of intersection is something that could
really potentially accelerate these
research. If you had the technical
competency to sort of work on the
analysis I was describing of finding the
electromagnetic resonant modes of a
graph and then analyzing its topology,
we would love to collaborate. That's
like the sort of content we dream of
producing in the next year or two.
Thank you. And thank you for having us.
It's been really, really appreciate it.
I appreciate that. Chris.
Nothing substantial to add. Just my
thanks. As you know, I've scribbled down
some thoughts about the Markov blankets
and about some of those different
research areas. As you know, we're
getting stuff from this as. Yeah. And
hopefully this helps reach a few new
people who might come up with either a
brilliant idea why something we've
missed, and this just can't work. For
some reason, we want to hear that as
well. But even more constructively ways
that this could be tested or built out
more gradually modeled.
Yeah. Thank you for having us. Cool.
New ways of thinking within even one
topological frame enables new action
selection in the area. And the era of
video chatting. We've made new
topological relationships, new
connectivities that then disperse yet
again. And so it
continues. Thank you all,
though. Thank you so much. Till next
time. Very lovely. Thank you. Amazing
stuff. See ya.